una polémica y breve gira por el golfo
el mandatario francés emmanuel mccants
se reunió este sábado con el príncipe
heredero saudita mohamed bin salman
mccrone es el primer líder occidental
que se entrevista con el monarca tras el
asesinato hace tres años del periodista
llama al hashtag y aparentemente en
manos del régimen saudita
hablamos absolutamente de todo sin
ningún tabú con bin salman y pudimos
plantear la cuestión de los derechos
humanos evidentemente la sensibilidad de
la comunidad internacional la reacción
es a raíz de lo que podría haber
ocurrido con respecto a la situación que
hemos escuchado ha habido un intercambio
directo
esperemos que efectivo y económico ni
zone conocido en occidente adicional
diga
un estratégico restablecimiento de las
relaciones que le ha costado las
críticas de los organismos de derechos
humanos internacionales que acusan al
político de intentar rehabilitar a ben
sallam como un actor importante en la
región marco tratando de rehabilitar al
hombre que torturó a mi hermana mató a
jasón
y cortó su cuerpo en pedazos creó la
peor crisis humanitaria en un país
vecino encarceló al primer ministro de
un estado extranjero pero todo bien mack
contiene próximas elecciones y necesita
sus tratos hechos otro de los temas en
la agenda fue reparar los lazos entre
arabia saudita y líbano sumido en una
fuerte crisis económica grabada también
por el bloqueo de la nación del golfo a
las importaciones hacia beirut sólo le
sommer caballé en lo que respecta a
líbano trabajamos juntos y llamamos al
primer ministro mikati hace unos
momentos para enviar un mensaje claro de
que arabia saudita y francia quieren
comprometerse plenamente son gay y pleno
el viernes macrón visitó qatar y
emiratos árabes unidos- firmando un
millonario contrato armamentístico
criticado por human right watch quienes
argumentan que estas armas son
utilizadas en la guerra y que ha dejado
en los últimos seis años miles de
muertos